right there is other big news here
besides the election tonight in fact a
big
story coming out of henderson several
people are dead
after a shooting near stephanie in
wigwam that happened earlier this
morning
let's head out to kate houston who has
been at the scene throughout the
afternoon has a live update for us
kate yeah that's right i'm just across
the street from the apartment complex
where this happened and henderson police
say that four people are dead another
injured in what turned into an
officer-involved shooting this morning
around 11 a.m police received a call
from the douglas at stone lake
apartments
the witness reported hearing gunshots
and seeing someone with a gun in another
apartment
police did find the possible suspect in
a parked car
while trying to make contact with that
person police were forced to use their
weapons
right now there are five people involved
in this incident
four of them are deceased one of them
being this possible suspect
and one was transported to an area
hospital the condition this person is
unknown at this time
there's no word yet on the ages or the
identities of the people involved in the
shooting
nor their relationship to each other
back out here live investigators
are still in this area at this apartment
complex and they may be out here for
several
hours as they investigate what sparked
this shooting this morning
reporting live in henderson tonight kate
houston 8 news now